era esta una situación Inevitable algo
que ya se veía venir
Buenas noches Andrés debemos de partir
que sí porque listros llegó con pies de
barro al gobierno recordemos que ella
ganó por el voto de los militantes no
por el apoyo de los diputados
conservadores y además la paradoja hace
que su intento de aplicar el
neoliberalismo de margaret thatcher no
funcionarán El Siglo 21
ahora qué dice la renuncia detrás sobre
la credibilidad del partido conservador
ya van cuatro líderes Stories en seis
años
es efectivamente más bien más que la
credibilidad habla de cómo el partido
conservador se ha aferrado y se aferrada
al poder 12 años de poder Tori y no
convocarán a elecciones porque no lo
pueden hacer pero las oposiciones lo que
está pidiendo simplemente pensar que en
el 2019 ganaron con mayoría pero desde
el 2016 como bien lo mencionaste 4 jefes
de gobierno en el en este periodo y todo
podríamos mencionar que tiene como que
es consecuencia del brexit un elemento
una política que los conservadores han
seguido intentando
instrumentalizar Y qué dice ahora toda
esta situación de la inestabilidad de
Reino Unido
la inestabilidad política porque el caso
de Trunks es muy interesante en términos
de la inestabilidad política versus
ofrente a la estabilidad institucional
administrativa pensemos que todos cuando
llegó al gobierno se rodeó en el
gabinete de sus leales despidiendo a
muchos funcionarios funcionarios que
sabían de la administración y finalmente
que se espera de quien sea elegido como
sucesor detrás
intentar un poco de dar credibilidad
pero no a la política británica sino la
política de los conservadores el punto
es Quiénes son los candidatos se ha
reducido a tres entre ellos Boris
Johnson el cual no sería la carta más
creíble justamente para intentar volver
y reducir la ventaja que en las
encuestas los laboristas llevan ahora en
unos 30 puntos